but first my thoughts at the end of day
38 America in shutdown now remember when
Trump said this the heat
generally speaking kills this kind of
virus so that would be a good thing and
it got cream for it one of the things
the person has been saying is that you
know by April if the warmer weather
comes it this may all just magically go
away or miraculously go away you've
heard from the CDC and FDA officials on
here they are not confident that it's
warm weather is going to rid the world
of this health officials around the
globe scramble to fight the deadly
coronavirus President Trump has a new
plan wait for warmer weather we owe the
snark and then today the virus dies the
quickest in the presence of direct
sunlight under these conditions and when
you look at that chart look at the
aerosol as you breathe it you put it in
a room 70 to 75 degrees 20 percent
humidity low humidity it lasted the
half-life is about an hour but you get
outside and it cuts down to a minute and
a half by the way I like that guy at the
briefing he was really cool I liked him
for the moment he started speaking
alright what's great news for all of you
being cooped up indoors is it a complete
change of course no but it's good news
the power of fresh air in sunshine we
all instinctively know that it's good
for our physical and for our mental
health it's pretty obvious but remember
in this new Kovach 19 time war for all
living in for the president's enemies
any good news for America is actually
bad news is it dangerous for you to make
people think they would be safe by going
outside in the heat
considering that so many people are
dying in Florida the new headline is
Trump is people to go outside that's
dangerous here we go
same old grouper the president and
people
these briefings they want to get
information and guidance and want to
know what to do that I'm the president
and your fake news I'm just here to
present Talent I'm here to present ideas
because we want ideas to get rid of this
thing and if he is good and if sunlight
is good that's a great thing as far as
I'm concerned well if you listen long
enough to Democrat governors and their
poodles and the press these days you're
gonna realize that there really is no
good news in this cove Adara no
developments positive it enough positive
enough to to get us to think that the
science or the data is changing to
justify reopening the states that really
want to open anytime soon now think
about it on Easter Sunday we knew that
New York's hospital system although
stretched in a few places would not be
overwhelmed we also knew that Governor
Cuomo's claim or insistence that they
would need 40,000 ventilators was off by
at least a factor of six guarding
against a collapse of our healthcare
system was the entire justification for
this national shut down if we don't
flatten the curve how concerned well if
you have a really massive increase in
cases there's no country or anybody in
the world that's going to be perfectly
prepared that's the reason why we want
to blunt that curve if you let the curve
get up there then the entire society is
gonna be hit at all well we knew weeks
ago that our hospitals would not go
we're not going to break under Kovan
because look now military hospital ships
are largely empty emergency Hospital
tents barely utilized no one who's
needed an ICU bed has been denied one no
one who's needed a ventilator was denied
one this should be celebrated the Trump
administration should get some credit
for these achievements we achieved these
very important goals in a very
challenging time the curve was flattened
but now that's not good enough now they
tell us we can't go back to our old life
until almost a new bureaucracy is
created to save
we have to put together a tracing army
this is gonna be a massive undertaking
good news is Mayor Michael Bloomberg has
volunteered to help us develop and
implement the tracing program Oh
fantastic
Bloomberg's in charge okay the guy who
doesn't think China's President Xi is a
dictator I'm going to be shocked and I
hope I am surprised but I'll be shocked
if New York truly opens up I mean like
the old New York before the election you
don't think so well that's just the way
I see things going might be wrong I hope
I am wrong
although 26.5 million Americans are now
out of work the president's top medical
advisors sole focus and it's kind of you
can't really blame them that is their
only focus it's this virus and today the
top guy threw shade on the testing issue
the media picked this up and then they
threw it in Trump's face dr. Scott you
said that the u.s. is not in a situation
where you can say we are where we want
to be with regard to testing capacity he
said we need much more testing capacity
as well as tests that were just not very
no I don't agree with him on that no I
think we're doing a great job in testing
I don't agree if he said that I don't
agree with him oh good I love that
because if we wait for a doctor foul
cheese seal of approval to reopen
America we may not have an America to
reopen at least not one we recognize I
have my own testing proposal you want to
hear it let's start testing the lamed
data and theories that have been
shifting ever since this crisis began
first it's very confusing first masks
didn't help now they're required in a
lot of states they do help first we were
told that millions and millions of
people could die then we were told the
models that forecasted millions and
millions of people could die were bad
then we were told the virus was far more
lethal than the flu that was terrifying
now we know it's likely to be closer to
maybe a really
flu season now courtesy of the antibody
studies on both the east and west coast
we see that the virus was circulating
for probably a lot longer than we
thought that means more people were
exposed to it and many of those had
innate immunity to it we found so far as
the statewide number is thirteen point
nine percent tested positive for having
the antibodies it means these are people
who were infected and who developed the
antibodies to fight the infection if the
infection rate is thirteen point nine
percent that would be about 0.5% death
rate
well that too is certainly better news
than we thought and we heard originally
about this virus it certainly though
doesn't mean we need to test three
hundred plus million Americans dr.
Burke's reference this the other day
we do test three hundred plus million
Americans created a new immunity
certificate for work and travel that
some are actually proposing the bottom
line is this most Americans desperately
want to get past this shutdown others
want to prolong it if you can believe it
or not for political reasons or maybe to
extract a few more policy concessions
the more damage we sustained the more
likely a radical restructuring of
America will follow
it's a democlass ORD hanging over our
heads right now the longer we stay
shutdown the less likely it is will
recover anytime soon and the more
American lives will be lost to things
like depression suicide addiction and
domestic abuse and of course the less
likely it is that Trump will win
re-election does anyone honestly think
that the Biden campaign actually wants
this country to open up anytime soon I
mean they obviously preferred him in the
basement
fewer missteps fewer gaffes well most of
the time we're here in the basement of
my home which is turned into a
television studio I'm not very familiar
with
was clear to me by that time the
president had no sense no sense of
science no sense of responsibility and I
and I just really it really worried me
that I worried that's to Joe if we don't
get this economy going again that man
could become president of the United
States
now that is far more terrifying than any
coronavirus and those are my thoughts at
the end of day 38 America in shutdown